so at this moment right now yeah where
are you in terms of your future and how
many projects you have in your mind for
the future yeah it's a really odd moment
um
both very wonderful and and confusing
because I have three movie ideas so
three movie ideas I toot to I I'm there
I even have the structure of all three
to some extent and so it's a very very
weird and interesting situation I'm
feeling you know I wish I could tell
them faster you know I wish I could get
there faster but there is no shortcut I
have to spend the six to nine months to
write it I have to storyboard for three
months and then then we have to
pre-production and then shooting in an
edit for as long as I can get every
single second you know I just finished
knocking like the like that like I would
say the three hours four hours before I
put my pencils down on knock of the
cabin I added one more line like I
called an actor and I was like say this
into your phone and and send it to me
right now I have an idea and put this
and I put it in it was like that you
know one last idea and then they were
like pencils down you can't you can't
put another idea in it so basically
you're saying that like literally every
two years from now for the next six
years most likely there'll be a movie
definitely but I'm hoping to do it a
tiny bit faster than that let's see if
my if I can handle it